y
[Música]
el presidente de chile gabriel boric
reemplaza a sus mayores aliados dentro
del gabinete tras el revés sufrido en el
plebiscito del domingo cuando los
ciudadanos rechazaron la propuesta de
nueva constitución además expuso que
sigue en el proceso constituyente
los sobrevivientes del tiroteo en la
escuela primaria de balde en el estado
de texas regresaron hoy a clases con
nuevas medidas de seguridad como diez
guardias más unas 500 cámaras y agentes
del departamento de seguridad estatal el
centro educativo busca dar confianza a
los padres tras la masacre de 21
personas en mayo
clijsters ya es la nueva primera
ministra del reino unido- y comenzó su
mandato bajo la promesa de superar la
crisis económica en su discurso
inaugural al frente del ejecutivo además
la líder conservadora dio a conocer su
gabinete para lograrlo tenemos análisis
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
noticias en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz iniciamos en chile el
presidente gabriel boric se realizó
cambios en su gabinete y nombró
ministros que representan una izquierda
más moderada el mandatario espera que la
sacudida en la que sacrificó a su
círculo más cercano aumenta su
gobernabilidad tras el plebiscito que el
domingo rechazó el texto de una nueva
constitución el objetivo es retomar el
proceso constituyente informe de arianna
villacorta es la primera
reestructuración del gabinete del
presidente chileno gabriel boric cambio
a sus ministros del interior de
desarrollo y familia de salud de ciencia
y tecnología de energía y a su
secretario de presidencia duplicando el
número de ministras frente al de
ministros 16 de ellas mujeres y 8
hombres y optando por personas de mayor
experiencia lo que supone un giro hacia
la izquierda más moderada y una
despedida a sus más cercanos aliados
confió
en este equipo que me acompaña para
liderar el reencuentro que tenemos que
ejercer en chile- con el proceso
constituyente que seguirá su curso
y con atender a las demandas de la
ciudadanía que clama por más presencia
por más respeto por más justicia y por
más igualdad esta primera gran reforma
se produce en respuesta al rotundo
rechazo de los chilenos a un primer
borrador de una nueva constitución para
sustituir a la vigente que data a la
dictadura de augusto pinochet y es que a
pesar de que en un plebiscito de 2020 el
80% de los ciudadanos votó a favor de
sustituir la constitución la propuesta
resultó demasiado radical para la
mayoría boliches está manteniendo
conversaciones con los líderes políticos
sobre cómo reactivar el proceso de
reescritura de la carta magna los
procesos de transformación social son
siempre de largo aliento
la historia la misma historia de chile
el lugar donde estamos hoy día nos ha
enseñado que los grandes cambios los que
perduran son aquellos que no se hacen de
la noche a la mañana
y que para concretarse y mantenerse en
el tiempo requieren ser abrazados por
las grandes mayorías
entre tantos cientos de estudiantes a
favor de la nueva constitución
protestaron frente a la moneda sede del
gobierno por más recursos educativos
algo que resultó en enfrentamientos con
la policía
ahora vamos hasta texas en eeuu porque
los estudiantes del pueblo de walter
regresaron este martes a la escuela por
primera vez desde que un hombre armado
mató a 19 niños y dos maestras en mayo
aunque los alumnos no están en las
mismas instalaciones donde ocurrió la
masacre el departamento de seguridad
pública de texas ha incrementado sus
estándares de seguridad mientras la
planilla de maestros se esfuerza para
volver a la normalidad y ayudarles a los
estudiantes en el regreso a clases la
historia la tiene juan pabló lucumí
con altas cercas decenas de policías y
mucho temor los estudiantes en igual de
texas volvieron a sus clases en el
fatídico 24 de mayo un hombre armado
entró a la escuela primaria rock y
disparó a 19 niños y dos maestras el
colegio permanece cerrado y tal vez sea
demolido algunos de sus antiguos alumnos
fueron transferidos aquí a la escuela
primaria de walt de la tragedia no se
borra de sus memorias pero con banderas
coloridas y camisetas en las que se lee
juntos nos levantamos y juntos somos
mejores las maestras intentan ayudar a
sus estudiantes en un nuevo inicio
escolar mientras tratan de darle
tranquilidad a los padres que dejan a
sus hijos sea lo que mi hija estaba
pensando estaba asustada sé que estaba
asustada
aunque las clases comenzaron hace
semanas en algunas partes de texas los
funcionarios del distrito retrasaron el
inicio escolar en balde y pese a que el
departamento de seguridad pública del
estado se comprometió a poner casi tres
docenas de policías en el campus más
cámaras en la instalación de una cerca
de metal de 2,4 metros de altura por lo
menos 100 familias del pueblo
inscribieron a sus hijos en escuela
virtual mientras que otras los cambiaron
a escuelas privadas yo estaba asustada
asustada de no recuperarla pero hicimos
simulacros todo el verano le enseñé que
si escucha algo en el pasillo ya sabes
sal por la ventana corre no te detengas
no grites ahora los niños tienen
teléfonos cada uno de ellos no creía que
los niños de esa edad deberían tener
teléfonos pero ahora debe ser así
después de la masacre
376 oficiales recibieron un informe
condenatorio de un comité de la cámara
de representantes de texas por haber
esperado más de una hora antes de
confrontar al tirador decenas de
personas marcharon en contra del porte
de armas y washington aprobó la primera
gran ley bipartidista sobre violencia
armada en décadas
cambiamos de tema el organismo
internacional de energía atómica
presentó su tan esperado informe sobre
la situación que se vive en la planta
nuclear de sap orilla que amenaza con
ser escenario de un desastre radioactivo
por los constantes enfrentamientos entre
las tropas rusas y las ucranianas dentro
de las recomendaciones presentadas por
la agencia de la onu se encuentra la
creación de una zona de seguridad y un
acuerdo para detener los bombardeos
andrés triviño tiene los detalles
aumenta la preocupación internacional
frente a un posible desastre nuclear él
oye a catálogo la situación en la planta
nuclear de sap orilla como insostenible
tras publicar su tan esperado informe
sobre los riesgos en la central luego de
que un equipo de expertos de la agencia
nuclear de la onu visitará la zona los
primeros días de septiembre rafael
grossi director general del organismo
expresó su preocupación frente al
consejo permanente de seguridad de la
onu físico
whiting and winding los ataques físicos
que estas instalaciones han recibido de
los cuales yo mismo puede evaluar
personal y si haces conjunto con mis
expertos es simplemente inaceptable
simple
le advierto que están jugando con fuego
y algo demasiado catastrófico podría
ocurrir safeplace el informe de 52
páginas presentó 7 recomendaciones para
la planta nuclear de sap orilla entre
las más destacadas se encuentran el
pedido de la creación de una zona de
seguridad y un acuerdo entre las partes
para que se detengan los bombardeos el
organismo también expresó su
preocupación por la presencia de
material y personal militar ruso el
involucramiento de funcionarios rusos
que interfieren en la operación de la
planta y el deterioro de los equipos así
como la dificultad técnica para su
reparación la planta ubicada en
territorio ucraniano pero ocupada por
las tropas rusas desde los inicios de la
invasión ha sido constante escenario de
intensos bombardeos de los cuales moscú
y kiev se acusan mutuamente
y
hablemos con la verdad cualquier daño a
la planta nuclear más grande de europa
en sap orilla o cualquier otra en
ucrania sea con intención o no se podría
traducir en una tragedia en la región y
mucho más allá todas las medidas
necesarias deben ser tomadas para evitar
tal escenario
el step es más vital con tu labor del
escenario pero sí informó que los
expertos se quedarán para mantener una
presencia a largo plazo en el sitio
france24 habló en exclusiva con el ex
presidente ucraniano petro poroshenko
sobre el informe presentado por el
organismo internacional de energía
atómica el ex mandatario insistió en que
el reporte no puede ser neutral cuando
se está hablando de energía nuclear y en
medio de las preocupaciones sobre un
eventual accidente radioactivo además
planteó una nueva serie o una serie de
propuestas adicionales a este informe
escuchamos
[Música]
ay
la misión del oiea es vitalmente
importante y el resultado es que no se
puede ser neutral cuando se tiene cuando
hablamos del terrorismo nuclear de rusia
no se puede ser neutral cuando hablamos
de la seguridad nuclear porque el
artículo 5 de la carta de la otan no
puede proteger eso pero creo que
necesitamos puntos adicionales en el
informe del oiea
en
punto número uno exigir inmediatamente
el regreso de la planta nuclear de sap
orilla al control ucraniano
[Música]
el punto número 2 el retiro inmediato de
todas las tropas rusas que ubicaron un
sistema de artillería exactamente en el
lugar de la planta nuclear
y esta es definitivamente la evidencia
de que putin está jugando
punto número tres es absolutamente
necesario desplegar las tropas de paz de
la onu con base en la decisión del
consejo de seguridad de la onu para
reforzar la seguridad nuclear esto es
crucial
el punto número 4 no debemos permitir a
rusia apagar la energía del sistema de
seguridad ucraniano porque el intento de
apagarlo va a aumentar
significativamente el riesgo nuclear
y en crisis
y con todo eso le doy la bienvenida a la
misión y creo que debemos trabajar duro
para continuar con el esfuerzo de
detener el chantaje ruso con terrorismo
nuclear
listos asumió al cargo como nueva
primera ministra de reino unido se trata
de la cuarta líder conservadora en 6
años que llega al poder después de la
salida de boris johnson tras los
escándalos que sacudieron su mandato
desde el número 10 de downing street
residencia oficial de los mandatarios
británicos trabas dejó claro que aliviar
la economía la crisis energética y el
sistema de salud pública serán las
prioridades de su gobierno para hablar
de ese tema saludamos en bogotá indicó
szeged y más aquella es directora de
maestría en derecho económico de la
pontificia universidad javeriana de
colombia señor a seguir de bienvenida a
france 24 cuáles son los principales
desafíos que enfrentar a todos en
materia económica que fue uno de los
temas que encabezó su primer discurso
como primera ministra
buenas noches muchas gracias por tenerme
mira el clima más importante es el
empobrecimiento de la población desde
2008 tenemos una situación donde en
promedio las personas en los de reino
unido perdieron 20 mil euros de su
patrimonio entonces eso va solo
empeorarse con la situación que en
octubre se espera un 80 por ciento de
subida del precio de energía eso
significa que cuando viene el invierno
la decisión una entre 5 personas va a
ser como o voy a aprender la luz o me
muero del frío
ahora cuáles serán las principales
características que la diferencia harán
de su antecesor el también conservador
boris johnson
mira la señora atrás es muy del gobierno
de boris johnson significa que grandes
diferencias no vamos a ver tal vez la
diferencia grande va a ser es que el
contendor de atrás para este puesto
original quien fue nada en el momento
ministro de hacienda de johnson no lo
permitió el endeudamiento lo que
justamente atrás está proponiendo atrás
justamente lo que dice para este jueves
de hecho estamos esperando los
pronunciamientos que va a haber una
financiación de alrededor de 40 millones
de libras para negocios
y 130 millones de libras para lo que son
de las tasas para la venta de energía y
todo eso para financiar de deuda pública
pues eso va a ser un endeudamiento casi
igual al endeudamiento
el mismo pandemia eso va a subir un 10%
del endeudamiento del país es un gran
campo bueno y en materia diplomática
cómo será la relación de reino unido
bajo el gobierno de otros con la unión
europea teniendo en cuenta que la
mandataria es una firme defensora del
éxito
yo no espero nada bueno de verdad nada
nada diferente de lo que fue boris
johnson aunque seamos honestos atrás en
una época entonces no estaba progressive
pero pero esto ya será tu cambio y es un
firme enemigo pues desde la unión
europea irás y cualquiera y de adreno yo
en la unión europea pero dejemos algo
muy claro atrás llega ya como resultado
de foto de
160.000 personas miembros del gobierno
conservador 1.5 por ciento de la
sociedad en este momento la izquierda
líder tiene una aceptación en la aste
enlace en crestas de 43 por ciento
mientras los conservadores sólo 28 por
ciento significa puede ser que tenemos
un gobierno muy corto
bien era idílico szeged y massa que es
directora de maestría en derecho
económico de la pontificia universidad
javeriana gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en france 24
muchas gracias y de esta manera
despedimos este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]